well it looks like the family here is
going to get a little bit bigger coming
in on the heels of sona's twin boys uh
looks like my wife and i are having a
baby as well congratulations that is
really exciting thank you that's right i
actually knew that i know knew we knew
we both knew and i'm a bad actor so i
just anyone listening who heard me and
just went oh congratulations good for
you i'm realizing now that sounds awful
yeah it's because i knew already and
i've known for some time but this is the
first time that you're telling uh the
listening public that's right it's far
enough along in fact we're not that far
out but i've known for so long that i
had to be a bad actor that sona when you
announced you had twins on the way i
wasn't gonna obviously reign on that
parade but i knew about my child on the
way but i couldn't say anything and just
you know it's it's interesting how you
have to do that but wow so conan we're
gonna be gone with children yeah yeah
you're gonna be alone well here's we
planned it i i
i hope this comes across the right way
but i pay you guys to podcast not to
have babies
[Laughter]
what's going on here seriously
everyone's like oh thanks for the check
conan
they do come regularly oh and something
else my partner and i had sex
and babies are coming
and we're gonna leave you
but we still want those checks now that
seems unreasonable
now you're deflating it a little bit i
don't think so i think i think there's
just a little bit of deflation happening
and this is a joyous occasion you're
talking about our paychecks well i'm
just trying to understand how this works
from a business point of view and i'd
like to go over i'd like to talk to some
of the people in charge of the podcast
your you know your adam sacks various
accountants that hard at work the show
they may say well this doesn't make
sense from a when you go to business
school they don't tell you about this
you know
you know i say that as someone who never
went to business school but i used to
walk around the business school
sometimes try and meet people what i was
asked to leave uh
i just thought it would be well those
people went to business school they
might know stuff and
i could hang out with them
it didn't happen it was weird
it was very weird and it was a bad
period of my life i would say business
school groupie i didn't go i just hung
out in the library but wow my point is
i don't think this is part of the
organizational team coco flow chart well
like sona said we plan this and and we
also know that my daughter's going to
grow up to marry one or if not both of
her sons
who knows what's going to happen then so
you're having a girl is that what you
said that's right that's it that's great
so i
you you're gonna be gone right because
you're gonna be helping uh your wife
amanda take care of your new child right
yeah that's the plan but maybe we'll be
staggered actually maybe sona will be
back because our due date's not till
september late september and again i
hate to maybe adam if you could just
jump in for a second do they get paid
while they're on what is it called
how does it work maternity and paternity
leave what is it what's the deal the
problem is that parental leave
protections are really strong in
california so as far as i understand
they they really can just
go on as long as they want have we no
problem no no but adam's on the adam as
on the right track he knows he knows
exactly
uh okay yes it is problematic and i'm
sure that there are these quote laws on
the books uh but if we've learned
anything over the past few years with a
good lawyer i mean have there been
challenges oh my god this is interesting
because i'm an independent contractor
and i had no idea that this was even an
option so i'm glad this is getting on
record yeah
conan wait a minute i i i think our oh
our lawyer oh great our lawyer is
available he's coming in now
oh you you have to pay it if you don't
want it what
sylvester stallone is your lawyer
uh hey you don't have to pay it if you
don't want to pay it
i have jax don't pay it it's not
something you have to pay so it's not oh
by the way i should probably introduce
uh my lawyer yeah this is uh this is
jason
giacometti uh oh god jason so you think
it's it's
crazy they're not working they're just
hoping
just help and uh raise their own kids
i know it's just that's the only part
that seemed weird to me is there a way
to maybe put them on a reduced pay
i think we could probably make that case
okay jason giacometti you're an
incredible lawyer and um a very good
boxer in the 70s
you fought in philadelphia uh and uh
against um
credible fighter
for the title and you almost won but you
you stuck by adrian
i just
just think you don't have to pay it
oh god all right well i'm glad our
lawyer was able to cut in and talk to us
briefly i here's the thing yeah i i know
you guys think i'm doing a bit and and
to a degree i am i'm doing like a bit
and some schtick
but then it does
i do get confused like how long do you
think you'll be gone sona would you be
gone like a year what are you [ __ ]
talking about yeah you're not going free
here
for paternity leave is typically longer
so i'll be two years
my mother had six children in four years
and she took no time off oh my god
babies were just flying out left and
right and then my mother was constantly
back to work that's what it was like
when i was growing up
no one said a child is born and wise men
gather and bring frankincense and myrrh
whatever that is
and uh that's when pete that's back when
people got excited about a spice can you
imagine today if someone was born and
you showed up at the door i brought you
some spices
i brought paprika and cumin
that's what you better send us i brought
paprika and cumin
and some basil leaves
okay
well this other person showed up with a
really nice
uh pram from britain and this person
gave us uh baby bjorn and this person
gave us a well i brought spice
cause that's what's in the bible
well thank god i um you've had two kids
yeah i took no time off well i'm but you
don't didn't you want time off it was
kind of crazy at home come on
oh she wasn't sleeping the babies
i was like well if i don't interview tim
robbins who will
i guess the option is we could not take
time off and just do these remote
recordings holding our babies up to the
mic yeah isn't there a way
to my other question as long as you're
holding the baby you're quote being a
good parent and i'm sure you're a
digital whiz gourley with with your
sonic abilities can't you remove their
crying and fussing uh digitally oh my
god oh no
no no if you're not gonna give us leave
these babies are going to be they're
going to be three babies screaming at
the top of their lungs during the entire
interview with the next obama what if i
have to breastfeed you'd get very
awkward if i like had a thing around me
and then was breastfeeding you you don't
even like you're saying cervix and today
stop it don't say servants
it's never been proven there is such a
thing
science is the jury's sell out on that
oh jeez no cervix some such thing uterus
placenta
like the female orgasm it is but a myth
um
i uh i'm concerned i'm concerned about
you guys leaving me because we make such
a good
trio
um you know me being sort of the alpha
but you guys
whatever i'm the sun and you're these uh
but you're very good planets that
revolve around me and oh my god lifeless
planets small
often why would we ever want time off
from this i know
i can't wait for this baby to come i
know i can't wait you guys are going to
introduce labor early
why would you want to induce at seven
months trust me
we work with amanda's pregnant again
it's two months after she just gave
birth well let me be uh in a rare moment
of sincerity uh i love both you guys and
i'm very excited for both of you you're
gonna be
amazing parents i do resent that you get
this thing called paid leave i still
don't get that i will again look into it
uh but
i will decide for now to pretend to be
gracious about it
um and uh but i'm really excited and uh
i promise that even
without the two of you who are so great
uh leaving temporarily will will keep
the fun coming here at conan o'brien
needs a friend i will not let you down i
will not let you down even though i've
been betrayed
by two of my cohorts
and their need to procreate